ich habe genau zwei Fragen an dich meine
erste Frage ist wie bist du zum Hip-Hop
gekommen und meine zweite Frage ist was
hat sich inspiriert zum Beispiel so
Texte wie zum Glücklich zu schreiben
oder andere Lieder die du aufgenommen
hast würde mich über eine Antwort freuen
und Ciao also was inspiriert mich zu
meinem Texten mich inspiriert alles was
ich um mich rum sehe glücklich den sehr
speziell auch gefragt er hat mich z.B
inspiriert als ich kein Geld hatte noch
keinen Plattenvertrag und
meine Freunde auch nicht so viel Geld
hat nur mein einfach so ein bisschen
perspektivlos zu Hause sitzt und ähm ja
einfach so denkt man man hat doch
eigentlich mehr verdient sondern reißt
sich doch jeden Tag seinen Hintern auf
und darum geht es eigentlich so z.B wie
glücklich und sonst
inspiriert mich Party und ähm
Herzschmerz und Freunde und wie bin ich
zum Rap gekommen durch sollten Papa
letzter Tag aber Sex siehst dir einfach
mal rein